فيا عباد الله اوصيكم ونفسي المذنبه
الخاطئه بتقوى الله تعالى وطاعته ولزوم
اوامره وكثره
مخافته اطيعوا الله والرسول لعلكم ترحمون
ايها المؤمنون واعلموا عباد الله ان
التقوى شعار المؤمنين ودثار الصالحين
ووصيه الله تعالى في وفيكم اجمعين فقد ق
قال الله سبحانه وتعالى اعوذ بالله السميع
العليم من الشيطان الرجيم بسم الله الرحمن
الرحيم يا ايها الذين امنوا اتقوا الله حق
تقاته ولا تموتن الا وانتم مسلمون صدق
الله
العظيم اما
بعد ايها المسلمون
في كل
عام وفي مثل هذه
الايام
نستذكر
مناسبه عظيمه على قلوبنا
كمؤمنين هذه
المناسبه هي
ولاده
سيدنا المسيح عليه
السلام عيسى ابن مريم عليه السلام سلام
وعلى نبينا محمد افضل الصلاه واتم
السلام
لذلك سابدا معكم بسلسله من
الخطب من اليوم ان شاء الله سبحانه
وتعالى وسابدا معكم ما تطرقت
اليه سوره ال عمران
وكلنا يقرا هذه السوره
المباركه التي سميت باسم هذه
العائله
تكريما لسيدنا عيسى عليه
السلام وال
عمران هي
عائله سيدنا المسيح عليه
السلام الله سبحانه
وتعالى
يقول ان الله اصطفى ادم ونوحا وال
ابراهيم وال عمران على
العالمين ذريه بعضها من بعض والله سميع
عليم اذ قالت امراه
عمران رب اني نذرت لك ما في بطني
محرره فتقبل
مني انك انت السميع
العليم فلما
وضعتها قالت ربي اني وضعتها انثى والله
اعلم بما
وضعت وليس الذكر
كالانثى واني سميتها
مريم
واني اعيذها بك
وذريتها من الشيطان
الرجيم فتقبلها
ها بقبول حسن وانبتها نباتا
حسنا وكفلها
زكريا كلما دخل عليها زكريا
المحراب وجد عندها
رزقا قال يا مريم قال يا مريم انا لك هذا
قالت هو من عند الله ان الله يرزق من يشاء
بغير
حساب الى اخر
الايات يقول القرطبي رحمه
الله قوله تعالى ان الله اصطفى ادم
ونوحا اي اصطفى بمعنى
اختار
والتقدير ان الله اصطفى
دينهم ان الله اصطفى
دينهم وهو دين
الاسلام لان معنى الاسلام هو
الانقياد لله سبحانه
وتعالى فحذف
المضاف ان الله
اصطفى دينهم وهو دين
الاسلام ونوحا
نوح عليه السلام وهو شيخ
المرسلين واول رسول بعثه الله الى اهل
الارض بعد ادم عليه
السلام وقوله تعالى وال ابراهيم وال عمران
على
العالمين روى الامام البخاري رحمه
الله عن ابن عباس رضي الله عنه ما
قال ال ابراهيم وال
عمران المؤمنون من ال ابراهيم وال عمران
وال ياسين وال محمد عليه الصلاه
والسلام يقول الله تعالى ان اولى الناس
بابراهيم للذين
اتبعوه وهذا النبي والذين امنوا والله
الله ولي
المؤمنين وال ابراهيم
اسماعيل
واسحاق
ويعقوب
والاسباط وان محمدا صلى الله عليه وسلم من
ال
ابراهيم وكذا ال
عمران
فالمراد هنا
عيسى عليه
السلام لان
امه ابنه
عمران قال الكلبي رحمه الله هو
عمران ابو
مريم وهو من ولد
سليمان ابن داوود عليهما
السلام وحكى السهيلي رحمه الله عمران بن
ماتان
وامراته
حنه وان هؤلاء رسل
وانبياء فهم صفوه الخلق
ذريه بعضها من بعض في الاجتباء
والاصطفاء
والنبوه قال عكرمه رحمه
الله ان حنه كانت عاقره لا
تلد
حنه كانت
عاقرا لا
تلد وكانت تغبط النساء
بالاولاد ثم
قالت اللهم ان لك علي نذرا ان رزقتني ولدا
ان اتصدق به على بيت المقدس ليكون من
سدنته وهو قوله تعالى اذ قالت امراه عمران
رب اني نذرت لك ما في بطني محرره فتقبل
مني انك انت السميع
العليم قال اهل التفسير رحمهم الله فقيل
ان سبب قول امراه عمران هذا انها كانت
كبيره لا
تلد كانت كبيره لا تلد وكانوا اهل بيت من
الله بمكان
اي ان الله سبحانه وتعالى اصطفى هذه
العائله
واجتباهم وانها في يوم من الايام كانت تحت
شجره فبصرت بطائر يزق
فرخا فتحركت نفسها
لذلك ودعت ربها ان يهب لها
ولدا
ونذرت ان ولدت ان تجعل ولدها محررا اي
عتيقا خالصا لله تعالى خادما للكنيسه
حبيسا
عليها مفرغا لعباده الله تعالى وكان ذلك
جائزا في شريعتهم وكان على اولادهم ان
يطيعوه فلما وضعت
مريم فلما وضعت مريم قالت ربي اني وضعتها
انثى يعني ان الانثى لا تصلح لخدمه
الكنيسه واني سميتها مريم
يعني
مريم خادم الرب في
لغتهم مريم بمعنى خادم الرب في لغتهم واني
اعيذها بك يعني مريم
وذريتها يعني عيسى عليه السلام
وفي صحيح مسلم عن ابي هريره رضي الله عنه
قال قال رسول الله صلى الله عليه
وسلم ما من
مولود يولد الا نخسه الشيطان نخسه فيستهل
صارخا من نخسه الشيطان الا ابن مريم
وامه ثم قال ابو هريره رضي الله عنه
اقراوا ان شئتم و اني اعيذها بك
وذريتها من الشيطان
الرجيم ايها
المسلمون
اعلموا ان حنه ام مريم كانت عاقرا وكبيره
في
السن مثل
جدتها ساره
العجوز زوجه ابراهيم عليه
السلام فحملت
باسحاق عليه السلام بعدما كانت عاقرا
ايضا وهذا
تمهيد من الله سبحانه وتعالى لان الله
تعالى يعلم خائنه الاعين وما تخفي الصدور
ويعلم انه سياتي جيل
يقولون ان عيسى هو ابن الله
تعالى ولذلك كان تمهيد من الله سبحانه
وتعالى لهؤلاء الذين قالوا هذا
الكلام ثم بين
لهم قوله
تعالى ان مثل
عيسى كمثل
ادم خلقه من تراب ثم قال له كن
فيكون
وهذه اراده ده الله سبحانه
وتعالى يبينها
لخلقه لعظيم قدرته في الخلق وهو الذي
خلقنا من العدم الى الوجود اذا اراد شيئا
ان يقول له كن
فيكون ايها المسلمون تابعونا في الجمعه
القادمه ان شاء الله تعالى وان كان للعمر
بقيه
حتى نكمل قصه سيدنا المسيح عليه السلام
واستغفر الله العظيم لي ولكم ولوالدي
ولسائر المسلمين اجمعين ادعوا الله وانتم
موقنون
بالاجابه ‏